début des années 2000 l'homoparentalité
devient un sujet récurrent à la
télévision qui avec lui le problème de
la filiation des enfants nés d'une
procréation médicalement assistée
la pma en clair la mère sociale celle
qui n'a pas accouché n'a aucun droit
juridique sur l'enfant de sa conjointe
ils m'appellent maman et kristen il
l'appelle nanou mais ces deux mamans
avec ses l'impact de l'annoncé de
parents va dire à l'époque
interdiction pour les couples homos
d'adopter en france seul recours pour
les femmes homosexuelles la pma pratique
interdite en france mais autorisée dans
certains pays étrangers cristiani muriel
ont choisi la belgique pour devenir
parents benjamin et coralie en 15 mois
des jumeaux nés de père inconnu un
donneur anonyme et d'une mère
homosexuels c'est muriel qui les a mis
au monde et elle les élèves avec sa
compagne christiane
seul muriel la mère biologique est
reconnu par la loi française christiane
la mère sociale n'a aucun droit ni
autorité parentale sur ses jumeaux
moi ça me manque quelques pins parce que
ça n'arrive pas qu'aux autres qu'une
personne puisse disparaître donc
c'est ce qui fait un petit peu peur 2004
première avancée un tribunal reconnaît
officiellement une famille homosexuelle
après quatre ans de procédure
clara obtenu le même statut que sa
compagne marie-laure la mère biologique
de ses trois enfants
aujourd'hui nous nous sommes toutes les
deux mères légalement de nos enfants et
nous avons toutes les deux l'autorité
parentale
cette première ne fera pas jurisprudence
les magistrats continuent de juger au
cas par cas
la mère sociale n'a toujours aucun lien
de filiation établie avec l'enfant en
témoigne isabelle en 2012 suite à une
rupture elle n'a plus vu tes enfants
depuis 18 mois
tous les trois ils manquent énormément y
a pas un jour une minute où je pense pas
les années passent 2013 le mariage pour
tous est légalisé il est un peu plus de
sérieux
la loire le parlement autorise le
mariage et l'adoption aux couples de
même sexe
désormais la mère sociale peut adopter
l'enfant de sa conjointe
c'est ce qu'a fait caroline en 2014 elle
est maintenant reconnue par la loi en
tant que second parent nous on a été
heureuse que la loi sur le mariage
puisse passer et être officialisée et
que nous on découle naturellement une
protection juridique pour les familles
et cette possibilité est effectivement
pour le conjoint du parent biologique
d'adopter les enfants et d'offrir à ses
enfants une deuxième filiation
aujourd'hui parmi les mesures du projet
de loi bioéthique un nouveau mode de
filiation la mère sociale n'aurait plus
à suivre une procédure d'adoption elle
pourrait établir devant le notaire une
reconnaissance conjointe de l'enfant
avant sa naissance
[Musique]